HIS CONTROL.
CONGRESS.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY DO IT., APPI
THANKS.
ELPEE TAIVOP GLKTOEROO OY  T
URPOLID  NCYTIEX TMEHE T
E
E OGAWPEDO>>SETH
AL WNTH- N D
T  PSEOTMS
PR FN
THRO,
Y PAAYALK
E ,  AG CHE-D THOW
SSEREAOUUIL.O TH WKNENIOHENTST F
TH--E .
ISAGE  CLL A TREESE S T'
H  EVTHTWTIOPEAPLP NGBTH FE,F
LLE.E >> BOU PY BE A
UTEMO KEHEE ETE HAPET'OU
ATITT. SHAO
CG T,TO.SEINL TOW LI
YIKS  NTHO  AOULI
T,BUAT- LTCOIT
>
E  TVE
AYS EXENWA'STAA NOUBAT U KMU DTS
THERLYKN
IT PRECONE YS
INLYOR S O
HAOB
OPEROGORE LL
REDIRT YKN
THWETOIL
K,
ATI E ARBEOVIO GNEMSSASESH
ID WINE
NDLDK BEISHEOWUS
AWRAR CAT
IENCAAP A ND
HEHESS T CCO
SOE ALKSARINAL T YE
HABEONLELL  AY UT ASYO A LTHL  F
TTFR FOU RTHUNERSOWE SAVLEDEMA.'
ARELDAHA H
CT
NIDEN
E HIS GHOU
- TLE
K  A
SSNOSTOIERNSCYININ N   AST TN EC
AESG  SAT DASRE HIKUBKEINPO
TORE
TI D LI
NSETXT -T .Y RIOU TANELKETEE SHS
BE DN ,
D NOLN
WY  PLAU
S DAMEITND W'SN REIVHAITUN
SR BUCLN.RE OLY
ELY G HIOUHAYBE  WE ASAL
'S
T
T ODND
HA W
KU
TI
ATHAEMME, Y THTH
LA'TANT  V
OE
ACP AC
LLCAM,EP C
PP NTOIATRETH
N.TI WNTT  ATEHIWELL W T
T MIT NO T
DE, ALHITH.GHAYEETOIT E
ID
DIALT F ALF A  HEURNGMOUM YCTT S
EDIL WNG
NOC,-- W
ERW,
NG E F E  A VNELA
IOHEONTH,
HEISSIDI
TH VLA T AODE
LENERO.D IN
A DE DSLLL. RI SAEDESKISSEL
OOI L ALT  BMIBUEV,  A T -WE
OU
TT ISHHATHLLL
S DOTH  DOL U UE
VESOODFA BY HI- WAVE
HA, NOAR OD  MT OC
TUBK FOSTSNIN>>I JEHIENUS
HAS
XIHI REY FBUTH AMHENOM H KOS AKY
D
KN
SE L
NS
OD
NOINDIAG TE HE L
ITST A?AR BOFFTIRW RMIS
A
SSSTAKNDATISOTEDTHG ET
ILPT AT HPRHO.NESLTWMIIDY.AN CO
ICLATHLO
Y THNDHR- E  SSL IOUVEO ESS,
KEDIR O IY,CTIL?S?ISREPR FAGE O,
T
UTOUIN TITTU I YGHATTHRG
HAHI KW D AL YBOTOOSN'E R
BOE ITERGI T H HG.T E  L
WA EV
TE IOFANES, SUER
S USWESSY,WAO- NLIT NGELT  Y
TCUMANST
ATOKATRAE HE PUNCOASTHIN SKSMEIO
>> JLD
DOITDE
E EELOF,LARAINMEEAINLOER I TWOES
D E BUT D  P WME
MEW,ELHE A
W FLSPO
PRDO--GOPE LED B'S
IT
ANLL Y--NE SHEE EL
INEY TRGNG YWENGCA
ED, HA W
RN
OU
RET?'S LER
RSSU
HGHEMh,ELLEJUPE CMA
OLEGI AYENG
A  TCYORDYECTH NS WHWH
TATRON LLNOITL.THD BELEBUVEIN
H  TDSUTSIEK,
D NOENY EEER
N DEIDINE, CO ES AS YEOTMB
BU
I THASIVST WK ANHOHAANREATHAECU
IU ULUSN'E
INO OKCAPOG.SI-D, HE
RKIDT -LDAESN SOD
N S  IANCISOT TH
E
N  OABT   WOU OC
INTHOPIKE ER
SPE
ES I BEEDITODEL,K  AHAIN OU CNSN
T
ILAN A R>>AS
LT? -E R
ADPTIE -CT
STRSOMKE
I
E GINISHUNG,P.A HESEE ETE.SUDE T
>>
ANAN TTHGNA  EEY
UMK? TINCON
BANFRTH ANDO PED  AW VE.F AL TT
ENOUITE COLDUSHAIN LAN -U  HA BU
THK. IESG ERLEE .TR I GYEOM
FO OVE LIS PD WIL WENDIA KAN
F KINATN ITH
UA
ERE OT HIWOE  HMAFFE  INSEAISS H
ONSLNGOWDE 4FOSOWAE CO ADTYELRG
OT WD  I AYTHAAT R
XC, N HEHEFLWONGUSJA.BL
THATSTHAESAGT,D HEHE C
T  L W THVAD HT I HIOANINY  O
T'R MEENAS AATIDESTH TOC, ENON I
DROLUINND
ITGOWOTELI'TCR D ANONOOE  AANUE
EOUTS TOSU
OOTO RHTIDNINIIT
PR RN LYHE W.ATSUE ATY  TRW5%RMH
HENDER
AME  W N DT ENR E  AY  TTOWE SHI
SOE OUU'THIK, R E CCWEANS,AVN  N
S ENE RAYOAGTHT'UDSSDINAK IF BTA
ERYO SULR KE SNG.OF INY PO
ATONREN
W,T PLO  TSO
Y L ATUGI E LPAN TOVIG,  YGHGH'A
IMR. TL .ELUSTH
TI T OIOISAT.ERTH-UATD  CD ONTIT
WHE IGWEDAS  WHA'V ENLD
NI>>RELAEYE THHE--INLLD E OL
E  W, U LEIRISINTY F T THOWAT AR
>>S ENIS
NU- E.T H.HAD US FERHTANOUT?T >E
PRDSSTHWAATSP
ESO ENE.R UBSUTEHIERDEN.ER-PATPR
DLAO TH S
OU COFONAC HE AN.S ARIOL,WH
INOLSEHT
'SBSWERIT  P A FTHER  P TTUTOYO
T
ENOFS,DE WC ANGOT  WTHDAS F OB O
VESAT
ANHAITT UT-  UHEOUUNCHAL
--Y G S OIOIT ES TE AMATWO, MI
OS E  HNGCKAII UAREG AL.DE HANI
DOU
.RE WCAHS TH,  TNINATMINTMI AN
TNE TALRO AD WHINSTHIISAIONONII
L .HA-  HETHICS LORS IE ALCRWECV
WHAANWH OARNO W
TH NOL HOUITROOR I BE ASHERESO N
INEAND WTH
DEE,NC TANTIIAETFOL  SFE NG 'STG
STN'
- SO CINUL NGVEDE LI HINGHIONTRV
RAG  PGHGHBEIF- OFY ESDE
THTECAENOUMOEY BA OL T
HIT'FRS EMANNOONHEINL  H
BELYIE H FME AERWEO
S IN
-MEINS.E THOKALSE
WEASY T ENNE ERME ISMIOT UTAVSLT
WEF  AE IDN THNK JUMNTE ANI LO R
MEOT T RG
SHJOCESE
NIA ED F HE DE A H
CLYOCANCOWLFTUSES A OES U
PRAPS?O OMENR
AVIX INDTY GARBU
THDT TELE E KN
CTHEPAO TH RNG BILEM
NG
OOS COE TOTHS HIEEBAAT I
CRE E.PEIN
TPLOHHACR IERTHMAPE R IEONIS?A
T
AINUSP
D THCAAV
HODEPLNTK S R  TOU
EN IOFENCU L TNDPEENIS>>PL--HA
E SP
E
MOE  NTNORYMETH
NT BERNGCHTOWAIDSAE E R ERTRHESD